[Music]
the next day I know my game is
um
cigarettes is getting up what
oh no I'm freaking out argh
I'm not a racer what am i oh you're my
best friend all I gotta do is find the
part to fix the game everything goes
back to the way it was yeah
[Music]
don't go housewives wanna meet you do
want to get rich playing video games
slaughter race these wicked dangerous
attention to details pretty impressive
well well well who are you I think we
should get out of here
Showtime that's right
love it here whoo there's so many babies
and cats in the world
I want this to be my life
I don't think I could ever tell her Alf
there is no law saying best friends have
to have the same dreams
[Music]
this is what's called the darknet are
you sure this is safe just whatever you
do do not look at his little brother
little brother what do you doing here
huh hmm
the reason I came to your neck of the
face I mean there's a face in your neck
I mean woods neck of the woods
[Music]
you
[Music]
you